allegiance to the flag of the united  states of  america and to the republic  for which it stands one nation  under god indivisible with liberty  and justice way to go kids uh you gotta  get your brother involved you're just  waving the flag which is cool and all  but  by the way we keep talking about getting  your dog to take part that might be as  close as we've gotten to actually  getting a dog  to do the national anthem if you your  friend your neighbor your  postman your favorite local deli owner  your dog whatever wants to do the pledge  of allegiance message us on the social  medias  we'll show it on the air and then alex  and i will talk about it  that is quite the call i know that's our  pledge for the pledge